GABE COHEN: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to the
Android Fireside Chat.
Thank you.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Yeah!
[APPLAUSE]
I'm already feeling
so good about this.
You have no idea.
So just real quickly,
the goal here
is to ask questions from
people who know a lot.
To get us started, I'm going to
have them introduce themselves
so you know what kinds of
stuff the people on this stage
represent, so you can ask
questions that are pertinent
or loaded or inappropriate.
Tor, maybe you can
introduce yourself
and we can go down the line.
TOR NORBYE: All right.
Hello, I'm Tor Norbye.
I work on Android Studio.
[CHEERING]
ADAM POWELL: I'm Adam Powell.
I work on the Android
Framework and UI Toolkit team.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL GARB: I'm Rachel.
I work on User Experience.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I work on the
[INAUDIBLE] Manager.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE BURKE: I'm Dave Burke.
I approve expense
reports for Android.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
DIANNE HACKBORN: I'm Dianne.
I work on the Android framework.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: I'm Rashad.
I work on Android Media.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN: Hi.
I'm Brian [INAUDIBLE].
I work on Java and C++
run times, libraries,
and compilers.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN SANDLER: I'm Dan Sandler.
I'm on the system
UI engineering team.
[APPLAUSE]
GABE COHEN: All
right, and I don't
think I introduced myself.
I'm Gabe.
I'm a product manager
on the Android Platform,
and this is pretty awesome
because I reprise my day job
of basically just passing
questions to other people
and then walking away.
So the goal is to ask
these people questions.
We have mics.
We have one, two, three,
four mics in the aisle.
All we're doing is
asking questions.
If you have questions about N,
about Multi-Window or Runtime
changes or [? Jitter, ?] or--
yes, people are lining up.
You win by lining up first.
AUDIENCE: I'm [INAUDIBLE]
from Hong Kong.
In some European
countries there are
many Android device have
been compatibility issue.
Most likely they are set up
also for the TV or mobile phone,
like Xiaomi.
Some of them do not
have Google Pay services
or Google framework inside it.
So is the Android team
doing something against this
to happen or is
there anything you
could say about these
changes on Android ecosystem?
DAVE BURKE: Ah, let's see.
Let me answer the question
like Hillary Clinton would do,
which is not answer
the question.
So, I mean, we spend a
lot of effort on our CTS,
our Compatibility Test Suite.
So, you know, literally
hundreds of thousands of tests.
And the whole reason we
do that is to make sure
that we have a
level playing field
so when you're writing your
app it'll run everywhere.
So, if anything,
we're making it harder
to build a compatible device.
But that's a good thing
for app developers.
And, yeah, I mean, I think
it's up to every manufacturer.
Like Xiaomi, they just
have a demo outside
of an Android TV device.
It's fully compatible
Android device,
so I think that's
one of the things
not everyone realizes is
that Xiaomi Android devices
outside of China are
actually compatible.
And then, you know, we have a
whole big partner engineering
team that works with
all of the device makers
to help them actually
build compatible devices.
So, yes, we had lots of
tests, but we actually
try to help them.
Yeah.
GABE COHEN: Yeah.
And just to add to
that, I mean, we also
work with folks who are
upstream of the device makers.
So, you know, folks like
Mediatech, et cetera, that are,
you know, maybe
building the [? SECs ?]
that are in the majority
of those phones.
You know, the image
that they build
is broadly used by
people, so, you know,
if we drive
compatibility with them,
we get sort of broad
device coverage.
But we definitely see, you
know, that it's a pain point.
So we're trying to
figure out, you know,
how we can better support those
manufacturers and upstream
from them the chip makers.
But it's a good question.
Maybe over here in the middle.
AUDIENCE: So I know it's not--
speaking of things that you're
going to release in the
future is kind of a thing
that Google doesn't
do, especially at I/Os.
However, this release is
probably the most forthcoming
in terms of what
we're going to see,
and with the Java
8 support that's
being added to the
runtime side, there's,
like, functions and streams
that's in there now.
I'm curious if we're
going to get things
like java.lang.invoke, java.time
to basically fill out--
complete, essentially,
the Java 8 APIs.
BRIAN: Right.
So I'm Brian from the Java team.
We really don't obviously make
forward-looking statements,
but java.time is definitely
something we're looking at.
The function stuff is there.
Some of the invoke
things are still coming.
But it's really we want to hear
from you guys about what is
important, and that's--
I encourage you to come.
Tomorrow we have
another Office Hours
for the Android
Runtime and Tools team.
We'd really like to
hear from developers
what's important to them.
We did sort of what we
had heard preliminarily
about what was the most
important things for Java 8.
Streams was one of
the important things.
Functional interface,
things like that.
Repeatable, repeatable
annotations.
But definitely
want to hear more.
Time is definitely
something we're looking at,
but it's just still
for the future.
AUDIENCE: Likes.
GABE COHEN: Cool.
Maybe over here on
the right, my right.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Hi, my name's [INAUDIBLE].
And a lot of framers
went recently
about Android going
to be transformed
into Swift and so on.
For me it doesn't make much
sense because if it's about
the [? low ?] [? thingy ?] then
going from Oracle to Apple,
it's a big old mess.
But this is not my question.
My question is a lot
of offline [INAUDIBLE]
and progressive web apps have
been, like, raised recently.
And my question is,
what do you think?
Is it going to take over the
Android development model
and, like, in the near
future, in the next two
years or something, we are going
to see only offline first apps
on our Android phones?
GABE COHEN: I'm not sure
I understood the question.
So is what going to take
over Android development?
AUDIENCE: So are we, in the
next two years or something,
are we going to see
offline first apps running
on the platform
instead of normal apps?
No longer developing using Java?
GABE COHEN: Offline first?
I'm not sure what
offline first means.
Android, historically,
has been designed
to have apps that work
without connectivity.
AUDIENCE: Well, here I'm not
talking about native apps.
I'm talking about web
apps that are designed
with offline first concert.
GABE COHEN: Web apps,
is that-- oh, web apps.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GABE COHEN: Yeah, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: So a lot
of apps has been
featured in other [INAUDIBLE]
talking about creating an app
and then push a button to
make it on the home screen
and then launch the app and it
works completely offline when
you don't have an internet.
So it feels like native app,
but it's running on [INAUDIBLE].
DIANNE HACKBORN: I would
say I'm not currently
looking for another
job, so I'm not
kind of anticipating that
in the next couple years.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE BURKE: I mean, to
answer your question,
like, we're interested in
pushing technology forward
on all directions.
Like, so the progressive web
app stuff is pretty cool.
You've probably
seen the Amp stuff,
so you get really
fast news articles.
We also have, like,
Android Instant Apps
which is a completely new area
that's somewhere in between.
And we're obviously always
involving our core app
framework.
So, you know, for
us it's like we just
want to give people
choice and options
and we're going to
push them all forward.
And we don't always
know the answers.
It's like, you
know, we build stuff
and then you guys build amazing
things on top that and we
learn and we reiterate.
GABE COHEN: Cool, thanks.
How about on the left over here?
We haven't gone
to that line yet.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I guess this one is for Dave.
Last fall you announced
the Pixel C tablet.
When we will see
the Pixel phone?
DAVE BURKE: Did I announce the
tablet or did someone else?
I can't remember.
GABE COHEN: He announces
a lot of things.
He can't be expected
to keep them straight.
AUDIENCE: Google [INAUDIBLE].
DAVE BURKE: I think I
technically didn't announce
the-- I think that was Andrew.
I was there.
I definitely was,
like, a witness.
A Pixel phone?
GABE COHEN: I think it's too big
to use as a phone, personally.
So, I mean, you can try.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVE BURKE: But it's pretty big.
If you take the keyboard off
it might be a bit closer.
GABE COHEN: Oh, yeah.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah.
That sounds like a great idea.
[LAUGHTER]
GABE COHEN: Back to this line.
AUDIENCE: So I'll ask the
question he kind of asked.
When are you guys releasing
first class Swift support?
DAVE BURKE: Swift.
GABE COHEN: You
know, the pop star.
DAVE BURKE: Actually,
how-- this is
really dangerous--
how many people
would like Swift in Android?
Yeah, fail.
OK, so we won't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, I think--
GABE COHEN: Who won the pool
on [INAUDIBLE] that question?
DAVE BURKE: --Swift's
a pretty cool language.
I think Apple-- I
mean, that obviously
is based on a-- Coco's
based on Objective C,
which is based on C,
which is 40 years old,
and a pretty old language.
Autorelease Pool gets you
so far, and so, you know,
they really needed a sort
of more modern language.
Obviously, you know,
in history, you know,
it's sort of like Java's
somewhere in between Swift
and C. But I think other
platforms needed it more than,
say, Android does.
Also, there's some
pretty nice Java 8
stuff with, like,
lambdas and streams
that were already mentioned.
But, yeah, no immediate plans.
I don't know where
that rumor came from.
It was kind of an
interesting rumor.
GABE COHEN: Cool.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
[INAUDIBLE], Ars Technica.
DAVE BURKE: Here's trouble.
AUDIENCE: My question is what's
the deal with the Maserati?
You guys have a car over
in the Android auto section
that's running Android
on the car as, like,
the main operating system.
It has, like, a nice
material design center
console and stuff.
There wasn't a blog post or
announcement or anything,
so what's the deal?
GABE COHEN: And I think
your question is when are we
going to get a Maserati phone?
[LAUGHTER]
No?
ADAM POWELL: No,
I think he missed
where to put his name in
for the drawing to win it.
[LAUGHTER]
GABE COHEN: I have no idea where
the Maserati thing came from.
DAVE BURKE: I think
Patrick got the Maserati.
It's really nice.
I saw it.
A really nice red Mas-- I
think it's a Quattroporte.
I think Patrick, who
runs Android Auto,
wanted to bring the car
and put it on stage,
but Sundar wouldn't let him.
That's a true story.
And so I don't know.
I guess we should
talk about it more.
But it's pretty cool, I agree.
If you guys haven't seen
it, you should check it out.
AUDIENCE: Well, are we
going to see Android on cars
now from you guys?
DAVE BURKE: I mean, a
lot of car manufacturers
are building Android anyway,
so we're working with them
on actually creating a
version of Android that
works in the head unit.
So, yeah, I think we'll
expect to see more.
I don't have, like, a
projection or a figure,
but, yeah, there's definitely
a lot of interest for it.
And a lot of the stuff
we do in Projected Mode--
so Projected Mode is when you
plug your phone into the car--
and we basically have
a separate display
and we actually project the UI
of the app in a sort of format
that's ideal for a car,
like, in a safe use.
A lot of that UI just
transfers naturally
when the Android runs
in the head unit.
You want that version of
the app on the head unit.
So there's sort of two projects
of Projected Mode and head unit
sort of are actually quite-- I
was going to use that horrible
word "synergistic"-- but they
both have some good overlap.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
GABE COHEN: Cool.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Question about Multi-Window.
I was wondering was
there a particular reason
why picture-in-picture was
left out of non-TV builds?
Like, you know, it
would be especially--
DAVE BURKE: I want to know
that answer. [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: It would be
especially useful on tablets
for, like, video apps.
So just wondering if there
was a reason it was dropped
and if it would be coming
in the future perhaps.
MALE SPEAKER: I guess I wouldn't
really say it was dropped.
There's a feature
flag that any OEM
can enable picture-in-picture
mode on any device, right?
The fact that [INAUDIBLE]
enabled on some of our devices
doesn't mean it's not supported
in the platform for any OEM
to pick up.
AUDIENCE: As far as I'm aware,
and, like, from the talks
I've seen, picture-in-picture's
only for Android TV.
Is that--
MALE SPEAKER: Well, was
that my talk yesterday?
AUDIENCE: No.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So if you watch, like, my
talk yesterday on Multi-Window
Mode--
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
--it has the right information
on Multi-Window Mode.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
GABE COHEN: Dianne,
you've trained him well.
AUDIENCE: Can I do a really
quick experiment now that--
just on the-- to continue
Dave's little poll here,
is anyone in the room interested
in using [? Kotlin ?] or other
modern JVM languages on--
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GABE COHEN: Everybody
just simultaneously
shout out the name
of a language,
and we'll get right on it.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, on the right.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I have a question specific
for Android N. So it's
pretty cool that now
Android Team is coming up
with the alpha and beta
version of Android N.
So what I learned that, like,
for this N-specific release,
even if, like, your app is
not targeting by the time
N is released, there are
certain features or APIs,
for example Multi-Window,
we have to consider, like,
because they would
be affecting the app
even if we are not
targeting for N.
So I was wondering if
there are any, like,
lists of features or
API that are available?
Or is there any plan to
make those available so
that you know the
developers can look at those
and make sure, like, at least
those are addressed before, you
know, the apps is-- for N?
DIANNE HACKBORN: Yeah.
So we kind of do a case-by-case
about whether, you know, we're
going to have applications
need to opt into something
or impose it on them
whether or not they opt in.
You know, Doze from N is a
good example where we said,
like, well, we're
just going imposes
this in all applications because
we need to do that for battery.
And we've tried
to-- whenever we do
that, we try to do
a lot of outreach
to developers to
prepare them for that,
so Doze happened that way.
Multi-Window's
happening that way.
We actually evaluated
Multi-Window
about what the impact
was on the applications.
We were debating about
whether to have it something
they have to opt into
versus just allowing
you to do in every one.
And we decided that
with the warnings
we have that it was
worthwhile allowing users
to use it for everything--
because they generally work OK.
So, you know, I don't know--
there's not a list of that,
but it's rare that we actually,
like, cause these-- you know,
like, make it so
applications need
to update to address things.
And we try to be pretty public
about that when it happens.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GABE COHEN: We should be
doing a clear job of--
or we should be doing
a good job of making
it clear in the
developer documentation
in the overview what the
required set of changes is.
I think we intend to do that.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, so one of the
things with Multi-Window Mode
in particular, like, one of the
kind of compatibility issues
that we saw with
some applications,
was applications that
tried really, really
hard to avoid ever having
their activity be restarted
for a configuration
change event, for example.
Multi-Window Mode, of
course, kind of generates
a new kind of those
configuration change events,
and those apps do tend
to have some problems.
And those are the sorts of
things that we kind of weigh
a little bit differently
because this kind of-- this
plays into a lot
of the guidelines
that we've given developers
since kind of day one
in terms of how to handle a
lot of the activity life cycle.
So basically I
would say make sure
that you pay attention to
some of the other developer
documentation and guidelines
for best practices
and recommendations about
how to structure your app
and keep your app functioning
under these certain conditions,
because generally
we'll use those
as guarantees that we
provide from the framework
to the application.
So, I mean, we may use those
same sorts of constructs
in new ways in future
versions of the platform,
and Multi-Window's a
great example of that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
OK, thanks.
I mean, the question was just
in the sense that, you know,
still previous versions I
would be very safe if I'm not
targeting [INAUDIBLE]--
GABE COHEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --Marshmallow.
AUDIENCE: And right now, like,
I saw this feature and also,
like, in the Android
[INAUDIBLE] I came to know that
for the network or
broadcast calls--
GABE COHEN: Uh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --while your
app is in background,
that will also be affected.
If--
DIANNE HACKBORN: So, yeah.
So the network
broadcast, you have
to be targeting N for that.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
DIANNE HACKBORN: So that's
their-- the only ones
I know of that we actually
changed on their apps
was Doze Mode,
Multi-Window-- and we
have the warning to users
about the application may not
be compatible, which we hope
means that you don't have
to stress too much about it.
I mean, your users will want
it, we think, so, you know,
you'll want to update.
But we're telling users
that it's not really
your fault too much, right?
And then there's also in N
the new video, a new picture
broadcast, that
we're just getting
rid of because those turned
out to be really problematic.
And we felt like there were
not a lot of applications that
were relying on them, so
it was worthwhile actually
applying that to everyone.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
GABE COHEN: Thank you.
TOR NORBYE: And
just-- in Studio 2.2,
we have some new link
checks which tell you
if you're using
some of these APIs
that are no longer
being called on N.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is kind of simple.
So there's a bit of a
best practice to decouple
[INAUDIBLE] as much as possible.
Like, nobody's going
to disagree with me.
Basically for us, as
Android developer,
it means taking code outside
of the activity of the fragment
and implementing patterns such
as ViPER and the Model View
Presenter.
And I was wondering
if you had planned
to integrate one
of those patterns
as a default for the
development in Android?
This same way for
example Microsoft
does with the MVC platform
where you create a page
and create the controller,
the view, and the model.
DAN SANDLER: I mean,
let anybody who
has written an article in the
last week about app development
patterns on Android
raise their hand.
[LAUGHTER]
DIANNE HACKBORN: So from
the platform perspective,
we actually really
don't care a whole lot
about how you decompose your
application, organize things,
and so there are best
practices that our Developer
Relations recommend that
other developers recommend.
We don't really want to encode
those very much in the platform
because it's kind of
something that really depends
on the application and
they change over time,
and it's better to let
those things evolve
and not be tied
into the platform.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE COHEN: Cool.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the Layout Inflation.
So it seems that the framework
does a four-name class
lookup when inflating a view.
That seems relatively expensive.
Are there any plans
to fixing that?
ADAM POWELL: Yeah.
There's an open bug to
look into doing some better
caching around some of that.
It's a known issue.
AUDIENCE: Great.
So we use [INAUDIBLE] only
framework called Scoop.
So one of the reasons for a move
away from using Custom Views
was that maybe potentially
take it to the next level.
And, you know, [INAUDIBLE]
with [INAUDIBLE] you
have, like, an ESL to define
interfaces which ends up
being just Java [INAUDIBLE] code
that gets in the APK and you
define your layouts this way.
And maybe in the future we
could have something really nice
like that.
ADAM POWELL: I don't think
we have any plans to support
that in the platform.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
GABE COHEN: Back here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I hope you'll bear with me.
This is a bit specific.
In emerging markets
we're starting
to see a proliferation
of multi-core devices.
They've got tons of CPU.
Unfortunately, they
got very, very slow
IO, which means that when you're
inflating large views which
have maybe resources
are loaded, you're
going to have 100 to
500 millisecond stalls
because the main thread is
still a point of contention.
At the same time, in
the View Framework,
there are things like
holding onto thread creation
to make sure that you don't
do the reparenting of views,
very, very specific
thread locking that
isn't necessary limited to the
way you're writing your code.
Is there any way we could
take a look at the frameworks?
Maybe allowing so
multi-threading possibilities
in View Creation and UI code
to help free up performance
on emerging market devices?
ADAM POWELL: So in terms of
the view inflation issue there,
you might take a look in
the more recent versions
of the support libraries.
I believe we put an Async
View Inflator in there that's
able to at least take the
inflation process itself off
of the main thread.
So that's one step
to some of that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: In the
demo on Wednesday
there was a demo of
the [? Duo ?] app,
and they mentioned that they
were using the quick transport
protocol.
And I was wondering if
that is enabled in Android
and, if not, if you're
planning on enabling that?
GABE COHEN: We're really
sure of the answer.
Just give us a second.
No, I don't think that we've
talked about incorporating that
into the platform.
I think this kind of gets back
to the comment Dianne made,
which is that can be
built above the platform.
That's how [? Duo ?]
is using it.
It doesn't necessarily need
to be built into the platform.
So we sort of take,
generally, an approach
that if it needs to be in the
platform, we'll consider it.
If it doesn't, we tend
to leave it out just
because there's a certain
amount of tax associated
with putting it there.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah.
So, like, Chrome, which is
an app on top of Android,
like any other app,
implements Quick.
And so, yeah, it's
better to do it
above the sort of core
framework so it can evolve.
And Quick is evolving.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE COHEN: Cool.
Over on the left.
AUDIENCE: Hello, hello.
Nice work on the
VR for Daydream.
And I'm wondering
is there a way to--
are you considering allowing
us to use Android Views in VR?
So 2D mixed with 3D?
Because there's a
lot of scenarios
we can do to make that
faster and up to speed.
And the second one is what
are the development tools
that you're going to support in
the future for VR development?
Thank you.
[? DAN SANDLER: So ?]
two questions,
platform and development tools.
TOR NORBYE: I don't think
we have anything to announce
for developer tools.
GABE COHEN: Yeah.
And I guess I hear
the request for being
able to use views in VR mode.
I can convey that
to the VR team.
We don't have a lot of
coverage from the VR
team proper up here, yeah,
but that's good feedback.
I think we take
that to the team.
Think you.
Cool.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: Hey, I'm Nelson.
I know Google's really
big on Dogfooding.
Is Google Dogfood
the Android Gradle
build system on larger apps such
as Inbox or Gmail or Chrome?
And then, as a follow-up
to that question,
I know when you first
install Android Studio
there's a box that asks
if you can collect data.
Do you guys have any data
on real world build times?
[APPLAUSE]
TOR NORBYE: Yeah, so most
of the large Google Apps
are built using an
internal build system,
but there are some big ones.
I don't know if
I can name names,
but we have a couple that we
use that are really, really
good for checking--
GABE COHEN: I'll
give you a hint.
It's on your phone right now.
TOR NORBYE: Yeah.
Yeah.
It rhymes with u-sic.
[LAUGHTER]
And what was the
second question?
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Data or
real world builds.
GABE COHEN: Yeah,
do we know about--
TOR NORBYE: Yeah, so we
actually had a presentation
this morning, what's new
in Android Developer Tools.
And so Steph Cuthbertson
basically went through a bunch
of slides showing some of
the aggregate statistics,
because we do look specifically
at that, at built times,
to make sure that [? Instant ?]
[? Run ?] is making the world
better.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE COHEN: Thanks.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: So hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm a low-level
cross-platform developer,
so I work with the C, C++.
And so I've seen
the presentation
about new developer tools.
I find it very great what
you are doing with C++.
I just want to ask
if there's going
to be more support
because, particularly
with native debugging,
that's always
been a problem in Android.
So the best native debug tools
that we had was printf and--
TOR NORBYE: Yeah.
We're working on that.
AUDIENCE: And the next
problem is the best profiling
tool for native code that
I have now is printf.
So it's going to be
supported with [INAUDIBLE].
Now we have native
debugging integrated
in the Android Studio.
Will we have native
profiling, for example?
Or better documentation
for C++ API?
TOR NORBYE: Yeah.
So we are investigating
performance profiling tools.
So let us know what
it is you want to see.
GABE COHEN: Thank you.
How about over here?
AUDIENCE: Continuing
the native theme,
are there any plans to support
native camera capture API?
MALE SPEAKER:
Actually in Android N,
you have native APIs to
access the new camera tool
interfaces that were released
several releases ago.
And with that you can
capture things natively.
So it's new in N.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
GABE COHEN: Over on the left.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just want to thank
you for the improvements
with Gradle build
speed recently.
It's great.
I started looking at Basil,
which is the beta build system
that you have, and
I'm just curious
is that something
you would recommend
for us to use or to start
looking at this year?
I saw that the
Android Studio support
is scheduled for late
this year on the Roadmap.
I'm just curious how
that might be going.
TOR NORBYE: Well, the
Android Studio team
is focusing
exclusively on Gradle.
AUDIENCE: OK.
OK.
Thank you.
GABE COHEN: Thanks.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So watching the
keynote, you know,
all this machine learning
stuff, Google Assistant,
it's all great.
But I think the most exciting
feature is Espresso Test Code
Generation in Android Studio.
[APPLAUSE]
So with that, my
question is now that it's
part of Android Studio and we
think that testing is actually
important, what are we
doing on the platform level
to ensure that new
versions of Android
don't break tools like Espresso?
So for example, making
sure that things
go through the
instrumentation API, you know,
that things are
properly hooked in so
that UI testing's
actually possible
for, like, new shiny features
of new versions of Android?
GABE COHEN: So the question
is stop breaking Espresso?
TOR NORBYE: I think that
was a platform question.
GABE COHEN: Platform,
stop breaking Espresso.
AUDIENCE: The question is
how do we not break Espresso
in future releases of Android?
And, let's say, new
widgets that come out
in the Support Library?
ADAM POWELL: Could
you give an example?
AUDIENCE: Well, for example,
like when RecyclerView
came out, you know, Espresso
didn't really support that.
It's still, you know, support
is still pretty crappy.
So that was, like, one example.
For example,
fragment callbacks--
when a fragment launches a
new activity, that does not
go through the
instrumentation API,
which doesn't let Espresso
[? intents ?] properly capture
it.
So things like that.
ADAM POWELL: Sure.
Let's go ahead and
talk after the session
and see if we can make a list.
GABE COHEN: Thank you.
It's good feedback.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's
is Alex from Runkeeper.
My question's around the
Parcelable interface.
So I think one of the things
that new and beginner Android
programmers kind of trip over
is passing data from their first
main activity to their second
[? my ?] [? first ?] activity.
And to kind of handle that
and implement Parcelable,
there's a lot of
boilerplate code,
so I'm wondering if you guys
have any plans to streamline
that or make that a built-in.
I mean, you can use
libraries right now,
like, Autovalue and some
other Parcelable ones,
but I was just wondering
what your thoughts were.
TOR NORBYE: So in
Android Studio we
have a quick fix that generates
the Parcelable implementation,
I think.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But then when you add new
properties to your object,
you know, it's just more code
to code to maintain the stuff.
TOR NORBYE: Yeah, agreed.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE COHEN: OK.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Gil.
I have two quick questions.
One, is there-- I don't
know if it's even possible--
is there a way to strip out the
[? Dex ?] [? Bytecode ?] from
the OIT files?
Maybe in a release
version of the build,
and that way you cannot reverse
engineer your [INAUDIBLE].
And the second
question, is there
any plans to integrate
Google Home into Android?
BRIAN: I'll take the
first one while you're
thinking about that.
So, no, we have no plans
right now to do that.
A lot of-- while we
do compile some things
into the [INAUDIBLE] file
for native execution,
we also fallback
for [? Bytecode ?]
for a lot of things.
And that's actually
happening even more now in N
with the move to the git.
So we'll start out,
we won't actually
have anything in
the [INAUDIBLE] file
except for your original
[? decks, ?] basically,
and some overhead
about verification
so we know to skip some things.
And then we are going
to slowly over time
expand that with
more native code.
So, no, it's really hard
for us to do anything
about just removing
the [? decks ?] file
because we sort of rely
on that to get started.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE COHEN: And the
second question.
DAVE BURKE: So when you
say integrate Google Home
into Android, what do you mean?
AUDIENCE: So for example, one
of the possibility-- I mean,
I don't see why would you
create a new hardware?
Why wouldn't you
just do a cradle
where you charge your phone
and that will basically
be what you talk to.
I mean, my Nexus 6P is
always on microphone, right?
I mean, you can
talk, OK, Google.
So why do new hardware?
DAVE BURKE: You definitely
don't own-- well, let's see.
It's useful having an
appliance that's always there,
that's hands-free,
that-- you know,
because you leave your phone
down, you forget it, et cetera.
So I think and appliance is
useful for that use case.
You know, it works really
well in the kitchen
or somewhere like that,
especially when you're, like,
using your hands for the stuff.
As for, like, sort of future
directions for Google Home,
that's definitely, like-- yeah,
I don't want to dare comment.
But, you know, we're
pretty excited by it.
It's pretty cool. there's
a lot of good stuff.
Some of the Android team is
actually building parts of it.
Like, we demoed, like,
lights turning on and off
and controlling
Nest thermostats.
That's using the Weave protocol
that we announced last year.
And so we're kind of
deeply involved in it,
but, yeah, nothing to
announce right now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE COHEN: Thanks.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thanks.
So I have one question.
It's great that over the last
few years we've been moving
toward the Support Libraries
and the [? Compat ?]
[? Libraries ?] so that we can
bring a lot of the new changes
into older versions of Android.
But as someone who works on
libraries more frequently,
or build systems, sometimes
having the Support Repository
can cause a lot of loopholes
to be jumped through,
especially when
building, like, pure Java
modules as opposed
to Android modules.
For example, an
annotation processor
that may need the dependency
on the Support Library.
All of a sudden we're using
internal Gradle APIs just
to access the Support Repository
during the configuration step.
So my request is please upload
the artifacts to Maven Central.
[APPLAUSE]
TOR NORBYE: Well,
as I understand it,
that doesn't allow us
to require a license,
and so we'd have to have a
lawyer look at that before we
could just upload them.
AUDIENCE: OK.
GABE COHEN: Thank you.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So if I wanted to port over
Android N preview to my device,
for example, like,
a Nextbit Robin,
do I need to recompile
the vendor proprietary
libraries to use with Clang?
And also, the
firmware, like the apps
bootloader an
secondary bootloader,
in order to actually boot up?
BRIAN: I mean, it's
sort of a-- that's
a different kind of developer
than most of the people here.
So we-- there is
a platform change.
We're moving in the platform
itself to use Clang more than
[INAUDIBLE].
But there's no requirement.
That's just what we're doing,
the direction we're going.
But there's nothing that's
going to magically require
you to use Clang to do a build.
AUDIENCE: No, I mean, if I want
to use Clang for the platform,
am I forced to use Clang
in the vendor libraries
to be compatible?
BRIAN: No.
No, you don't have to.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BRIAN: You can mix and match.
GABE COHEN: Thanks.
Here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So my question is
are there any plans
to launch a new
initiative like Android 1
but on a more global scale?
Because in many
emerging markets,
there is a very big
fragmentation problem
across the lower-end
phones, especially when
working with hardware and the
sensors and the radio chips.
So the problem is
there is not, like,
a spec for the
lower-end phones, so I'm
very interested in hearing
what you have to say about,
you know, the
lower-end, the emerging
markets and things like that.
DAVE BURKE: Let's see.
What can I say?
We're working on stuff
internally about,
like, how do we make it easier
to build a device that is great
and that's easy to upgrade
and get security patches
and apply new desserts.
And so we're looking at sort
of the Android open source code
base itself and
thinking about, well,
where are the pain points
when you're upgrading
a device from, say, N to O?
Like, can we make it
easier for people?
And it's something
we're investing time in,
but I can't really talk
about the specifics of it.
But the goal would
be to make it easier
to build more uniform
devices, if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
GABE COHEN: Thanks.
How about over
here on the right?
AUDIENCE: I believe it was also
the same question [INAUDIBLE]
measure diversity of the
mobile devices in the market.
How can you make it
easier for the OEMs
so they can just plug and
play just like a [INAUDIBLE]?
Is there a new-- or is there
APIs, is there special APIs,
just for the new version?
Because this diversity is
making most of us as developers,
I believe, frustrated because
we buy every time the latest
version or the latest mobile
to have the latest version
and when we start to
debug on these devices,
we find a new version.
Like, for example, Marshmallow.
I believe it's not
more than 10% had been,
until today, had been
deploying Marshmallow,
and you are now
announcing Android N.
GABE COHEN: Yeah,
I totally hear you.
It is similar to the
previous question.
Just to build on what
Dave was saying, I mean,
we look at the OEM
workflow from taking,
you know, AOSP from us and,
actually, even earlier drops
that we give them
before we release AOSP.
And we're trying to
minimize all of the work
that they have to do in
order to bring up, you know,
a major release or
even, like, a patch.
I think that's both figuring
out what kinds of features
they have to build
downstream of us
so that they don't have to
build those or reconstitute them
on top of the latest
code base, rebase.
I think it's trying to figure
out where they're customizing
things that involves
them putting code
all over the system and trying
to limit where that code goes
so that it's fairly
self-contained when they have
to repatch against a
newer version of the OS.
I mean, we're very much
thinking about that.
We're working with OEMs,
talking with them constantly.
I mean, a lot of
what we do is trying
to figure out how to
streamline the process
and make Android platform
more complete for them
as consumers of the platform,
because we recognize it creates
a significant amount of pain
when they make changes all up
and down the stack
and it's very diverse
across multiple devices.
We really like it to be
contained where possible.
So, I mean, it's true, but
appreciate the feedback.
We're working on it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE COHEN: Thanks.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: So I have a questions
about activity life cycles.
So currently when you're
in an activity and you,
you know, you
rotate your device,
the whole activity
gets recreated,
which is great because
you can load new resources
and react to the whole thing.
At the same time, this comes
with a lot of overhead.
You have to somehow cache
everything and then, you know,
get [INAUDIBLE] somehow.
And it creates a
lot of bugs-- it
tends to create a lot of bugs.
It also seems very expensive
because the whole thing
gets recreated.
You have to instantiate
objects again.
So you can obviously opt-out
and don't do anything about it,
you know, but I was
wondering if you had any plan
to create a more lightweight
layout handling orientation
changes where, let's say,
the views can just animate
to new places and that's it?
All the activity variables
would just retain their state
in memory instead of,
you know, developer has
to deal with the whole thing.
GABE COHEN: Got it.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Well,
I think, you know,
if you have resources
changing based on orientation,
then I think that our
only choice is really
to recreate it.
Because trying to go and
rebuild things and load
views with different resources
and that kind of stuff,
I think it's just kind
of a losing battle.
So if you don't want it to be
recreated, then tell it not to
and do your UI based on
the orientation, based
on something, yourself.
You'll just have to
handle that yourself.
And, you know, if you have to
do two-pane versus one-pane,
or whatever you're
doing, you know,
it can be relatively
easy or complicated.
It just kind of depends.
You know, I don't
see anything, like,
in the middle between
those that we're
going to do that would,
like, be really useful.
ADAM POWELL: So
part of that as well
is that you can
reduce the recreation
time by reducing
the amount of data
that needs to be recreated.
Kind of that secondary data
that normally hangs off
of your activity
or your fragments
or whatever it may be.
So if those things
can be brought down
to some sort of model layer
within your application that
can install persist
across those changes,
then that can really alleviate
a lot of the performance issues
that you might run into.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So there is-- I think
there are a lot of apps
that all that
happens is, you know,
you just changed the view.
Only thing that happens-- I
mean, there is really no-- what
I'm trying to say
is like there are
a lot of-- for a majority
of the apps, I would say,
there is really-- it's
just a view is changing.
You're just, you know,
loading a new resource
and moving stuff around.
So I was wondering if
you guys are working on--
DIANNE HACKBORN: So, well, I
mean, if the view is changing,
then you can just
say, like, you know,
handle the configuration
change yourself.
And actually, I expect you'll
be seeing applications doing
that more with Multi-Window,
because as you resize windows--
you know, it becomes more
noticeably expensive when we
have to recreate an activity.
So there's kind of more
incentive for developers to go
and handle that themselves.
You know, for some
background, the reason
why we did it this way
is partly because when
we did the Android and the
whole saving and restoring state
and all that kind of stuff
and killing processes
wasn't really something people
had ever really done before.
And so we really wanted to
encourage the developers,
like, you have to
actually do that.
And so making the
orientation change,
which the G1 really
had to support because
of the physical
screen moving, really
kind of helped us
push that into, like,
well, developers stating
and restoring state
is really important,
so you need to do it.
If you do it here, you'll
get to take advantage of it
everywhere else.
And so that kind of gave a
kind of common push into that.
And, you know, these
days I think people
understand that more so
it's not nearly as, like,
important to really, you
know, push developers
in that direction.
And like I said, I
think Multi-Window
is going to be starting
to, like, have us,
you know, kind of more--
there's more encouraging of them
handling the resizing
and stuff yourself.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE COHEN: How about over here?
And by the way, we're
running a little low on time,
so we're probably
going to get maybe
two more questions out of this.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'll make mine quick.
Can you offer anything on
pressure-sensitive screen touch
support?
Can you share
anything officially?
Or unofficially?
DAVE BURKE: I can tell
you how we think about it.
We think of it as really just
an accelerator of long press,
which is sort of what it is.
What we don't want to do is
have a system that's, you know,
you don't want have, like, tap,
long press, force press, right?
We think that long
press and force press
should be the same thing.
The advantage of it
is that force press
means you get there-- you don't
have to have a timer and wait.
And then I guess there's, like,
shortcut APIs and stuff that
came and went?
You want to take that?
DAN SANDLER: I
dont' know, Rachel,
if you want to say
something about this, too.
But, yeah, I'll second
what Dave said about UI.
We haven't yet seen
a compelling case
where users can
meaningfully distinguish
between the force press and
the length of the press.
But I should say that if
you are building a device
and you want to put a
panel like that in there,
we already have excellent
APIs in MotionEvent for you
to be able to capture the exact
pressure that's being applied
to the screen right now.
So any app that is looking
at these pressure APIs,
maybe because they're
using the capacitive sort
of approximation of pressure you
get from a lot of displays now
or because there's an
actual stylus attached
with an active pen
tip, those apps
would get access to that
pressure as well as long as you
plumb it up to the correct
slots in Input Manager.
GABE COHEN: OK, maybe
last question here?
AUDIENCE: OK.
I have two questions.
My first question--
GABE COHEN: No, no.
There's only one last question.
AUDIENCE: OK So
it's regarding UX.
I feel like she's left out.
UX, the navigation
within the activities,
is changing all the time.
First we have the action-- first
we have Tabs then Action Bars
then Hamburger Menu.
And I don't see any
consistency even
within the Google Applications.
I mean, YouTube changed
from a Hamburger Menu
than Tabs, Google Play,
et cetera, et cetera.
And it's hard to keep changing
the user's navigation.
So what do you think is the
best navigation system today
to offer to the user?
RACHEL GARB: Well,
it really depends
on the structure of your app.
The reason why you're seeing
more navigation patterns come
into place is there's
more variety of things
that people do.
So, I mean, your best source
is the material design spec,
and it will provide
tips and tricks
on when to use the Hamburger
Menu, [? Nav Drawer ?] verses
Bottom Tabs verses Top Tabs
and other patterns like that.
But, you know, when you
have, let's say, a really big
information hierarchy
and you have
lots of different sections,
a Navigation Drawer
is great for that because
you can have a long list.
You know, there's a
lot more room than,
like, horizontally
scrolling through Top Tabs.
Bottom tabs are
good if you have,
let's say, two or three
or four just really
core equally important
sections in your app.
Then that's good and people
can switch between them.
You know, we're
always-- our teams
throughout Google-- are
always experimenting
with new patterns, new needs,
and our Material Design
Team works with them
and then, you know,
we work on coming
up with a standard
that then we can publish
and share with everybody.
GABE COHEN: Cool.
Thank you.
That's all the
questions we're going
to be able to take up here,
but thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]